ja herr altmaier
sie haben ja eine öffentlichkeit gesagt
es wird keine arbeitsplatz durch corona
vernichtet ihr kollege herr scholz hat
gesagt jeder bekommt das was er braucht
wie stellen sie sich das vor ort also
müsste so langsam ein bisschen als klare
linie irgendwo darstellbar sein kredit
für unternehmer ist tolles schön um
jetzt erstmal zu überbrücken
aber das macht also meine unternehmen zu
retten
einer meiner angestellten sollten und
meiner familie zu retten aber das kann
sich sein dass ich mich bis über beide
ohren verschuldet also ist ja dann wird
sie auch unsere schultern abgewälzt und
am ende des tages steht der mittelstand
der die meisten angestellten in diesem
land hält die meisten
sozialversicherungspflichtigen job seit
einfach hält steht mit leeren händler
und wird einfach im stich gelassen
da wo ich das so langsam beantworten wie
das dann jetzt gestaltet wird vielen
dank
lieber einmal der wirtschaftsminister
ist heute bei uns wir freuen uns sehr
dass sie bei uns zu gast sind und sie
sind bei bild wie es sich für bild
gehört natürlich damit konfrontiert dass
corona bei den menschen im land bei der
wirtschaft beim mittelstand im land
auslöst ein dringender punkt den wir
hier eben gerade gehört haben von einem
hübsche ist vor allem die frage was
mache ich denn wenn meine bank sagt ja
natürlich kriegen sie sofort hilfe geben
sie uns bitte eine sicherheit ja also
ich hab ich ja ganz bewusst in dieser
pressekonferenz mit olaf scholz die
manche auch als historisch bezeichnet
haben gesagt wir wollen dass kein
unternehmen insolvent werden muss und
kein arbeitsplatz verloren gehen muss
nur aufgrund der korona krise wir können
natürlich keine garantie geben für
unternehmen die schon vorher am abgrund
standen aber wir wollen helfen dass die
unternehmen durch halten können und
dafür haben wir ein maßgeschneidertes
angebot das erste ist kurzarbeit
das machen wir damit kann man die
arbeitnehmer alle arbeitnehmer zu
kurzarbeit null nach hause schicken und
sie werden vom arbeitsamt von der
arbeitsagentur bezahlt das zweite ist
wir haben ein umfangreiches kredit
programm gestrickt was unternehmern wie
dem großartigen jungen mann den wir eben
gesehen haben
helfen soll und dann kriegen wir in der
tat rückmeldungen dass das von hausbank
zur hausbank unterschiedlich angewendet
wird das ist nicht der sinn der übung es
gibt einige die sagen wir geben dir
keinen kredit denn wir wissen ja gar
nicht wie lange du nicht produzieren
kannst wie lange die krise dauert ja
himmel herrgott es war das ziel dieses
programms dass man diese zeit
überbrücken kann
und dann finde ich dann ist es nicht in
ordnung dass man sich darauf beruft um
kredite zu verweigern der zweite punkt
ist dass wir natürlich auch wollen dass
bei den sicherheiten die kirche im dorf
bleibt natürlich darf man einem
unternehmen das ohnehin insolvent
geworden wäre dann nicht noch eine
lebensverlängerung geben zu lasten der
steuerzahler aber es kommt darauf an
dass von unternehmen die eigentlich
gesund und erfolgreich waren
hilft das zu überbrücken und dann muss
man auch sehr pragmatisch vorgehen
wenden bank eine schulter hat der immer
seine verbindlichkeiten bedient hat der
immer als schuldner alle voraussetzungen
erfüllt hat dann ist es auch geboten und
gerechtfertigt kredite zu geben das
alles wissen der olaf scholz und auch
ich und wir arbeiten daran wir werden
praktisch stündlich mit den problemen
konfrontiert unser ziel ist es in den
nächsten tagen klarheit zu schaffen
um sicherzustellen dass alle
mittelständler an das geld kommen was
sie brauchen um ihre arbeitsplätze und
ihre unternehmen zu sichern
es ist nicht in ordnung wenn banken
solventen normalerweise solventen
geschäftspartnern unternehmen schuldnern
in solchen situationen die kredite
verweigern
ganz konkret der hübsch ist ein gutes
beispiel und hübscher ist jemand der
gesagt ich stehe jetzt masken ja ganz
konkret die bank sagt ihm bitte über
schreibt uns dem grundstück piste
belastet ein grundstück was soll er tun
was ist der satz den er der bank sagen
soll oder ihr wort hat gewicht soll er
ihnen diese schreiben zu schicken
also eher kann es mir zu schicken dann
kann es olaf scholz zu schicken ich kann
natürlich nicht als ferndiagnose über
den bildschirm
einen konkreten kredit fall beantworten
aber die zielrichtung ist klar wir
wollen diesen unternehmen helfen dass
sie am markt kleinen im übrigen wenn er
masken herstellt
auch da sind wir bereit mitzuhelfen dass
klar ist ja kann sie über einen längeren
zeitraum an den bund verkaufen
auch da muss klar sein dass die
investitionen die getätigt nicht nach 14
tagen wieder vergeblich waren das alles
organisieren wir übrigens in einer
rekordzeit wir haben noch nie vorher ist
geschafft in so kurzer zeit das möglich
zu machen
wir haben die soforthilfen für die ganz
kleinen unternehmen mit 50 milliarden
euro
die haben wir ende letzter woche war das
paket fertig und es sind bereits mehrere
milliarden ausgezahlt auch hier in
berlin
begegne ich täglich kleinen
mittelständlern mit 2 34 beschäftigten
die sagen da hat mir das geld ist da
das haben sie parteiübergreifend gut
gemacht der zweite punkt ist dass wir
auch ein hohes interesse daran haben
dass das mit der kurzarbeit funktioniert
da haben wir das problem das gesetz ist
klar aber es sind so viele anträge
gestellt dass die bundesagentur in
vielen fälle nachtschichten und
übersichten machen muss dass zu
bearbeiten
auch da müssen wir bereit sein
beschäftigte aus anderen bereichen zur
verfügung zu stellen um das zu lösen und
das dritte ist mit den banken ja dann
müssen wir über die banken auf sich über
die bafin auch dazu beitragen dass die
banken klare auslegungs regeln an die
hand bekommen damit sie wissen wie wir
dass zum start aus wollen wir reden mit
den banken wir reden mit der
kreditanstalt für wiederaufbau die das
ganze koordiniert und ich gehe davon aus
dass wir mitte der woche aus diesen
anfangsschwierigkeiten draußen sind